violenta tivo sarà quello di parlare di
un aspetto della creatività che non sarà
quella dell'artista ma è quello della
forse più vicino allo scienziato e al
tecnologo che è quello di fare le stesse
cose meglio o di fare cose che non si
fanno ancora e questo la chiamiamo
innovazione di cosa stiamo parlando
stiamo parlando di tutto quel lavoro che
viene fatto in tutto il mondo per creare
qualcosa di meglio da vivere da fare da
ottenere vedete questi due grafici
sinistra ci sta quant'è la produzione
mondiale di articoli tecnici e
scientifici se sommate i numeri viene 2
milioni all'anno
quello di nesta dice quanto si scambiano
di questi articoli è un vero e proprio
mercato un vero proprio flusso che
determina il lo sviluppo
dell'innovazione sia in una zona
industriale a pensare cosa vuol dire
questo
in tutto il mondo arriviamo serve a
definire che cos'è un flusso di
innovazione normalmente fino a qualche
tempo fa c'era il mercato dell'acciaio
le acciaierie e tutto si sviluppava
partendo dalle materie base dalla
metallurgia arrivava fino alla
produzione degli impianti ghiacciati a
questo era per tutte le i vari settori
di mercato chiamiamole così e non si
spara essi parlano pochissimo fra di
loro
questo è un esempio io sono il lavoro
nello spazio facciamo satelliti e
qualcos'altro anche e questa è la
filiera dello spazio cioè si fanno
servizi di telecomunicazione di
osservazione della terra di positivi
posizionamento cioè il navigatore e si
ottiene questo attraverso varie
questioni
poi sono arrivate le nuove tecnologie
cioè la elettronica informatica alle
biotecnologie
e iniziato a succedere che per esempio
quelli che facevano l'informatica
potevano dire a quelli che facevano
elettromeccanica che potevano loro volta
scambierà usare studia i loro metodi per
poter scuotere cioè agitare il crogiolo
dove si fa l'acciaio cioè dove si mette
dentro carbone ferro e ottenere a parità
di materiali qualità di tutto il resto
un acciaio migliore quindi sono
tecnologie che complemento non si creano
i concetti di multidisciplinarità e
interdisciplinarietà cioè il fatto che
servono più disciplina per trattare in
maniera compiuta non certo una certa
questione e questo è quello che stiamo
vivendo adesso adesso abbiamo tecnologie
innovative che vi sviluppano altre
tecnologie innovative che non so che non
producono ancora un prodotto finale cioè
conoscenza che produce altra conoscenza
che poi farà arrivare un prodotto finale
quindi abbiamo quello che diciamo una
serie di prodotti intermedi che si
scambiano ma facciamo un esempio
concreto le nanotecnologie ne avrete
sicuramente sentito parlare bene in
questo grafo vedete che le
nanotecnologie le posso usare per
tantissime cose dal tessile
all'agricoltura alla medicina
all'elettronica
ma questo gruppo ci dice anche un'altra
cosa che per esempio se io voglio
sviluppare le applicazioni per i denti
le cure dentarie le protesi dentaria
io ho un percorso per arrivarci ma ne ho
anche un altro che mi porta sempre allo
stesso risultato però passando
attraverso stato diverso qual è la
differenza tra questi percorsi e che
magari uno è più veloce
un altro mi da dei risultati migliori un
altro costa di meno e non è a priori uno
meglio dell'altro a seconda di quello
che mi serve scegliere il percorso
giusto quindi
vedete si è complicata la faccenda
quanto si complica a questo punto
permettetemi di scarsi una una piccola
variante storica se io posso avere vari
percorsi cioè da una stessa tecnologia
possa arrivare a vari punti ecc
ed è così ampio lo spazio di cose che
posso fare le rivisto le nanotecnologie
con la nuvola di cosa intorno diventa
importante su cosa focalizzo le attività
di sforzi e quant'altro in particolare
ci sono quattro tecnologie che negli
ultimi anni sono veramente di impatto
che sono le biotecnologie le
nanotecnologie l'informatica è in quel
senso più specifico e le tele scienza
cognitiva l'intelligenza artificiale
cosa di questo genere e si è creato un
concetto nuovo di tecnologie convergenti
cioè ne possiamo avere tutte queste
tecnologie che per loro natura si
mischiano per creare cose nuove che non
sono quelle righe origine ma allora
diventa una cosa fondamentale per cosa
le finalizzo queste cose che queste
tecnologie che chiamiamo tecnologie
convergenti cioè questi sviluppi
tecnologici che si che si muovono
assieme come nel tempo facessero un
cammino molto simile hanno delle
finalizzazioni sociali cioè la cosa che
sta caratterizzando questi anni
nell'innovazione nei flussi di
innovazione che si sceglie quale
l'implicazione quindi c'è una scelta che
c'è alla base di quello che sviluppiamo
questo della scelta tenetelo presente
perché non è così banale perché che
queste tecnologie convergenti sono per
esempio quelle che ci supportano nella
vita quotidiana
se volete internet in quanto tale
esistesse una tecnologia
convergendo vari ciò sicuramente
intelligenza artificiale per il data
mining sistema di telefonia e
quant'altro questo tipo di tecnologie
proprio perché vanno a incidere su
sociale hanno una caratteristica di base
che quella che non si vedono nella vita
cioè meglio funzionano meno ce ne
accorgiamo perché ci permettono di
vivere in quello che alcuni chiamano
ambient computing cioè essere sempre e
comunque connessi e new millennium sui
ragazzi nati dopo il 2000
naturalmente sono così quelli over 50 ci
provano va così così e così andiamo
avanti allora diventa critico definire
qual è l'obiettivo comune
io ho preso le cinque priorità della
commissione europea negli ultimi sei
anni
la prima è l'invecchiamento attivo e
salubre
la porta era naso importante che
l'obiettivo è la base cioè il fine è la
base su cui da sviluppare tutti gli
sviluppi lo stesso per la gestione
dell'acqua lo stesso per quello che
potremmo chiamare sostenibilità urbana e
della mobilità lo stesso sul quella che
adesso si chiama economia circolare cioè
il fatto di riuscire a produrre materie
prime
riciclando quelle che già usato lo
stesso cielo sull'agricoltura
da questo punto di vista permettetemi di
fare un esempio di quello che va dove lo
spazio qui dell'agricoltura ma che
c'entra tramite lo spazio si può
sviluppare assieme ad altre tecnologie
qui sono già che convergono su un
obiettivo per esempio la resa
agricoltura di precisione cosa vuol dire
che lì con trasmissione che io siccome
riescono ad avere una tecnologia molto
buona ebbene le cose bene nello spazio
cioè in quel chilometro quadrato
contrada nevica
il grande meglio le posizioni cioè dare
il concime quando serve proteggere le
coltivazioni si sta arrivando tanto
estremo e quant'altro quanto vale questo
l'agricoltore della napa valley quelli
che fanno il vino associati andare in
questa direzione e il loro rispetto
non è stato del 70 per cento sulla
cooptazione
ok vi rendete conto quanto vale tant'è
che sono fatti il satellite per conto
loro
allora qual è il flusso che c'è dietro
un in questo caso sulla parte dello
spazio c'è una parte di ricerca che
confluisce nella parte che su da
supporto alla parte spaziale che si
declina per esempio di invecchiamento
attivo tutto né le attività fatte per
gli astronauti e quando non sono nè che
ci puoi versare che l'hanno appendicite
li devi curare devi tentare di prevenire
l'anti hedging questo crea opportunità
per cosa migliorare la vita qui in
questo caso riporta la frase della
commissione per i cittadini dell'unione
europea
da questo punto in poi alcune
riflessioni che vorrei condividere con
voi sulle conseguenze di tutto quello
che ho detto adesso la prima cosa che
tutta questa massa di informazioni ed è
tanta e l'innovazione può nascere in
qualunque posto fra vale due milioni di
articoli solo per articoli scientifici e
tecnici quindi niente medicina niente
psicologia niente sociologia tutte
queste cose e quindi c'è un primo
problema
troppa informazione diventa l'umore non
riesco più a selezionare quello che mi
serve
moltissimi di voi e vi saranno avranno
visto che su internet
ogni tanto fai le cose piega mi dà
sempre quello che non volevi subito c'è
più colte da sempre la solita risposta
mentre tournée cercarmi un'altra e così
via
questa si chiama entropia cioè energia
in questo caso informazione non più
utilizzabile anche se disponibile
questa cosa qui non è banale
pensate un'azienda se non è attenta
all'innovazione arriva un concorrente
che fa una cosa diversa da lei e vende
il suo stesso prodotto a un prezzo
minore oppure vende un prodotto
nettamente maggiore e sta fuori dal
mercato quindi avere proprio
informazione e pericolosissimo se ne 80
non riesco più a sta dietro vi pare che
fosse de gaulle che dicesse che diceva
che ci sono varie tre modi per rovinarsi
le donne il gioco ma il migliore della
ricerca scientifica e quindi il caos di
tante informazioni e pericoloso e quindi
la devi giocare l'innovazione a stanno
in quella zona quel in quella cresta in
quell'urlo sulle del caos che è
fondamentale ma come viene percepito
dalle persone questa cosa qui una prima
percezione è quella per esempio di
pensare che quello che sta avvenendo
toglie lavoro le aziende licenziano per
che automatizzano quindi sto perdendo
lavoro ma questo non è il problema più
grosso problema più grosso sociale cioè
la percezione più brutta e quando la
gente dice ma cavolo se questa cosa qui
abbiamo tutto per poterlo risolvere
pensate a certi situazioni ospedaliera
cioè fatemi fare ad esempio della
calabria
cavolo perché lì non si deve avere una
buona sanità c'è tutto in questa mancata
promessa poi porta a un secondo aspetto
che quella che io chiamo fiducia pigra
cioè guardate che non è vero che le
tecnologie da sole risolvono i vostri
problemi risolvono i nostri problemi
siccome alla base c'è una scelta su cui
finalizzo le mie attività su cui
finalizzo di mie ricerche e l'uomo che
sempre decidere quindi i problemi non
sono nelle tecniche
sorgiva ma in quello ma come le uso e
quindi non è vero che sono altri che
decidono per voi non è vero che
l'evoluzione necessariamente questa e
nella capacità di tutti di capire e di
saper giudicare e saper indicare questo
lo potremmo dire con una frase molto
semplice più grosso è la trasformazione
più grosso il timore per riprendere
quello che diceva prima il nostro amico
la quantità di persone ordinarie che
fanno cose ordinarie molto maggiore di
quelle di che sono ordinarie fanno cose
straordinarie e normalmente le ultime
talvolta che erano problemi alle prime
quest'anno s'è sempre vera allora qual è
il punto che noi abbiamo a disposizione
un enorme potenziale che questo
potenziale e un flusso che attraverso
tutto il mondo
il punto di base e come verranno gestite
queste informazioni
se volete un grande potere che viene
messo a noi a disposizione ma come
diceva come vedete la mia cultura una
cultura fumettistica ma da grandi poteri
derivano grandi responsabilità
questo che sta avvenendo i flussi
tecnologici e con di conoscenza che
stanno avvenendo che stanno cambiando
sicuramente il mondo del lavoro che
stanno cambiando la vita quotidiana sono
loro a nostra disposizione
siamo noi che dobbiamo saperli governare
è stata di gestire e da questo punto di
vista permettetemi l'ultima cosa
l'educazione la formazione è
fondamentale e il mito di cercare subito
un guadagno
fatemi fare l'esempio di un bel fido del
mio amico che andato a londra per
studiare il si è messo a fare il
cameriere un ottimo cameriere brevissimo
che però non ho studiato dalla smesso di
studiare oggi per governare tutte queste
cose che è necessario studiare per cui
ho uno lo fa da solo o non lo fa
seguendo qualcosa
ma alternative a questo non ve ne sono
grazie
[Applauso]